the Kentuckians for the Commonwealth
would be one organization to Google
online and find out a more in depth
response to your question and so I would
be repeating some of the discussions
that I've heard when I've been on the
tour and also visiting with people in
the region my first observation is how
many jobs are there actually with
mountaintop removal you all did not see
the machinery altogether but its massive
it's akin to the tar sands removal of
petroleum and tar sands now in Alberta
the largest environmental altering
project in the history of the human
family it's going on now in Alberta so
between the Appalachian mountain top
removal and Alberta those are just
massive projects sometimes the film you
get the impression well what are they
flying over one side or two sides there
are five hundred sites that we saw that
you're you speak up in your homeland
those sites are not going on
simultaneously on there's companies that
will go from one and deplete the seam of
coal and then they go to the next so
they leave behind what is supposedly
restored mountaintops flatten
mountaintops but i think you could see
it's very little growing even years
after that the airport where the plane
took off of and it don't know if you
noticed in the background it was all
mountain top removal so they've made an
airport and the coal companies have
proclaimed that that's one of the uses
that can be made of mountaintop removal
they also make claims ironically for
setting up wind power on top of
flattened mountaintops there are issues
with regard to that wind is
significantly diminished when those
mountains are set down but the
employment of
a question at the heart of your question
is there are more people employed by
traditional in underground mining so I
don't think Kentuckians for the
Commonwealth are saying and coal mining
in Kentucky or and West Virginia where
these to the mountaintop removal is most
extensive but rather aren't there ways
of getting the coal that we might
explore that would be less
environmentally damaging because if you
think of it for a moment again they the
devastation of that all of the mountain
that has been removed is legally to be
trucked into a disposal site and so the
breaking of that law is just a gray
giuse the overburden as it's called is
simply dumped in the valley so the
blocking of streams and the polluting of
students literally the deadening of
streams is the kind of it's very
difficult to fathom what would motivate
a company to do that and so the profit
motivation is clear but I think the
issues become couldn't we do it in ways
that would also employ people so your
question is is very good it's very
appropriate question and it is the
concern of an organization like
Kentuckians for the Commonwealth and of
others who are raising resistance to the
project